everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something I believe it you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you're a genius a legit
Bonafide genius you should be off there
changing the world I believe it you have
that talent you have that capabilities
most people don't most people one day
don't believ in themselves enough to
actually go off and Chase it and two
don't go off and explore to find the
thing that they have genius at that they
could be Michael Jordan at Warren
Buffett at and instead you try to
photocopy somebody else's life you try
to be the next somebody no you're a
genius let's go let's chase it down